Вы не достигнете значительных успехов и
достижений на самодисциплине и воле.
Самодисциплина и воля - это прямой путь
к выгоранию и депрессии. Почему
самодисциплина и воля настолько
переоценены? Давайте сегодня поговорим
об этом. Почему важно это знать и
понимать, что самодисциплина и воля не
гарантируют успеха. Более того, они
скорее приведут к выгоранию и депрессии.
Потому что люди, глядя на успешных э-э
людей, неправильно трактуют причины их
успеха. Они видят, как успешный человек
каждый день занимается рутинными
операциями, что-то делает, каждый день
что-то делает, каждый день, а он а не
нарушает график и так далее. И люди
думают, приписывают это качеством
самодисциплины и воли. Они думают, что
только благодаря самодисциплине и воли
этот человек достигает всего этого. он
заставляет себя, он преодолевает себя и
так далее. Потому что самодисциплина и
воля у нас ассоциируются плотно с
преодолением, с преодолением каких-то
препятствий, барьеров, борьбой и так
далее. И очень часто многие люди,
которые не могут добиться успеха, они
оправдывают себя тем, что, ну, у меня
нет самодисциплины, у меня нет воли и
так далее. Как будто это такие какие-то
компоненты, которые необходимы, чтобы
достигать успеха. Так вот, ээ, основное
заблуждение в том, что люди неправильно
трактуют -э сам источник, э, или, будем
говорить, причину а успеха. На самом
деле самодисциплина и воля - это
краткосрочные механизмы. Это механизмы
краткосрочной концентрации энергии на на
одном каком-то деле. Вы не можете
постоянно жить в этом режиме. Вы не
можете долгие годы жить в этом режиме.
Два основных способа
работать в, делать регулярные действия и
работать в этом режиме, это первое,
заниматься любимым делом. То есть, если
вы занимаетесь любимым делом, то вы
достигаете успеха, не имея ни
дисциплины, ни воли. Почему? Потому что
само любимое дело автоматически, э, вам
дают эти качества и свойства, такие как
настойчивость, последовательность,
регулярность. И второе, но, э, не так
много людей, которые могут найти своё
любимое дело, но основное, благодаря
чему успешные люди достигают успеха и
богатые становятся богатыми - это то,
что они превратили достижение цели в
привычку. То есть они не могут не
достичь своей цели. У них это стало
привычкой, и это у кого-то
сформировалось с детства, с детства
интуитивно. Большинство людей, а,
успешных людей, они интуитивно это
делают. Во-первых, что они делают? Они
не ставят тех целей, которые не будут
делать. А это сильно отличает их от
других людей. Многие люди делают цель,
не связанную с тем, насколько она они
будут это делать или нет. Есть такое
хорошее правило, которое гласит:
"Никогда не начинайте то, что можете
бросить. и не бросайте то, что начали.
Так вот, успешные люди - это, как
правило, те люди, которые никогда не
ставят тех целей, которые они не будут
достигать. Это первое. Второе, они
никогда не ставят целей, которые дорожку
которым они не видят. То есть они сразу
декомпозируют, насколько это реально,
нереально. То есть, если это какая-то
цель слишком большая и нереальная, они
просто её держат в уме, но ставят
промежуточную цель и её декомпозируют на
конкретные шаги. Таким образом, они
сформировали у себя привычку э
достижения целей. Как эта привычка
выглядит? Как она формируется? Привычка
формируется за счёт петли обратной
связи. Первое, вы должны, вот в казной
философии есть такое понятие, когда вы
ставите настолько маленькую цель, что
даже для вас она кажется смешной.
Первое, научите себя так. Это прямо
можно себя тренировать. Ставите сначала
маленькую цель. Почему нужна ставить
нужно ставить маленькую цель? Чтобы
повысить вероятность её достижения. Раз.
А во-вторых, чтобы действия по
достижению этой цели не вызывали у вас
психологического сопротивления и
дискомфорта. Вы ставите маленькую цель,
потом делаете действие. Второе. Потом
достигаете результата. Третье. Потом
обязательно себя вознаграждаете.
Поэтому, когда ставите цель, обязательно
прописывайте, что вам будет за это после
достижения результата. То есть, а как вы
себя вознаградите? К чему это приводит?
Это приводит к тому, что вы получаете
удовольствие от достижения результата.
В результате растёт ваша самооценка. А
когда растёт ваша самооценка, вы
следующую цель ставите чуть больше.
Повторяете цикл, вам всё нравится, ваша
самооценка растёт, и вы ставите цель
чуть больше.
Почему это важно? Дело в том, что люди
представляют дорогу к успеху как дорогу
полную препятствий, барьеров, каких-то
опасностей и так далее. И они, а,
думают, что самодисциплина и воля
помогают преодолевать эти препятствия,
то есть бороться, а, перебарывать и так
далее. На самом деле, с кем они борются?
с кем они борются. Вот давайте поймём,
кто ваш враг. Так вот, на самом деле они
борются со своим подсознанием. Ведь
именно ваше подсознание включает
прокрастинацию,
лень и отвлекается на различные факторы,
которые никак не связаны с вашей целью.
Почему так происходит? Потому что ваше
подсознание управляется вашим мозгом,
рептильным мозгом, который отвечает за
который работает по принципу: "А что мне
с этого будет?" И в результате, когда вы
ставите цель, а ваш мозг ставит цель, а
ваше подсознание эту цель не приняло, то
вашему мозгу приходится бороться с
подсознанием. Подсознание не даёт
энергию, а вам за счёт самодисциплины и
боли приходится её выдирать. подсознание
отвлекает, а вы должны концентриро
тратить энергию на концентрацию, а
подсознание вас отвлекает от вашей цели.
А почему она отвлекает от вашей цели?
Потому что ваше подсознание не видит
смысла, не видит для себя смысла в этой
цели. А в чём подсознание видит смысл?
Подсознание, как я говорил, это то
место, где живёт ваш эгоист. Оно всегда
работает по принципу и отвечает на
отвечает на вопрос: а что мне с этого
будет? И когда человек чётко понимает,
что мне с этого будет, подсознание
разблокируется и перестаёт
сопротивляться, и вам легко достигать
целей. И вот когда вы делаете петлю
обратной связи, то есть привычку,
формируете привычку достижения целей, вы
ставите сначала небольшую цель и
подсознанию говорите: "Ну, ваш мозг
говорит: "Дай чуть-чуть энергии".
Поэтому цель не должна вызывать сначала
психологического дискомфорта. Потом вы
делаете действия, достигаете результата,
а потом вознаграждайте себя. Ну как
можно вознаградить себя? Достигли
какой-то цели, сходите в спа, сходите в
баню, сходите в дорогой ресторан, на
крайняк попейте кофе с шоколадом. Ну,
обязательно какое-то вознаграждение
должно быть, чтобы ваше подсознание
зафиксировало, что цель, действие,
результат всегда приводит меня к
удовольствиям. Всё это всегда доставляет
мне удовольствие. И таким образом у вас
выработается вот эта привычка, что цель
- это всегда удовольствие. Движение к
цели - это всегда удовольствие. Это не
борьба, это не преодоление препятствий.
Это всегда удовольствие. Наверняка у
каждого из вас в вашей жизни случалось
такое, что какие-то дела дела давались
очень легко, какие-то цели, а какие-то
дела давались очень сложно. Вот,
напишите это в комментариях, интересно
будет почитать, и вы увидите этот
паттерн. Каждый раз, когда вы
вознаграждаете себя за результат, вам
хочется достигать сле следующей цели.
Каждый раз, когда вы боретесь, а то, по
сути, вы всегда боретесь с самим собой.
Вы боретесь со своим подсознанием. А кто
победит в борьбе с самим собой, итог
известен. Ваш ум никогда не победит ваше
подсознание, потому что подсознание
формировалось миллионы лет, а ваш ум
формировался буквально
десятки, сотни тысяч лет. Это называемый
неокортекс, именно кора головного мозга,
которая сформировалась совсем недавно.
Поэтому он называется неовый кортекс,
новая кора.
Поэтому при достижении любой цели всегда
помните, что все препятствия и барьеры
существуют не вовне, они существуют в
вашей голове, в вашем подсознании.
Именно ваше подсознание создаёт все
препятствия и барьеры. Именно ваше
подсознание делает действия сложными.
Именно ваше подсознание не даёт вам
энергию и мотивацию двигаться дальше. И
если вы выстроите правильный процесс, то
вам не будет необходимости в
самодисциплине и воле.